changer de téléphone tous les trois mois
juste pour te la jouer sur les réseaux
sociaux grâce à des photos en turbo
gigapixels de tes petits raviolis vegan
cuisinés dans une petite péniche
autogéré qui tourne au soleil et ben
c'est comme adopter un panda rouge juste
pour le disséquer bon c'est un peu fun
mais c'est pas très logique
[Musique]
chaque année nous générons
collectivement 45 millions de tonnes de
déchets électroniques et ce chiffre ne
cesse de croître à une vitesse
inquiétante comme on les balance
n'importe où ces déchets s'échapper les
éléments toxiques qu'il contiennent
plomb zinc arsenic mercure etc et
contamine donc les eaux et les sols
mais ce n'est pas tout il diffuse
également des perturbateurs endocriniens
qui rendent les grenouilles complètement
folles et nous font écouter leur disque
des mains et enfin les déchets se
dépouillent de leur métorora vous savez
ceux qui coûtent si cher à extraire et
qui auront bientôt disparu alors que
faire le premier geste indispensable
c'est d'effectuer un tri à la source si
toi aussi tu rêves d'un autre monde et
ben il faut pas jeter ton téléphone au
même endroit que les bouteilles en
plastique Bertrand
[Musique]
dans un second temps il faut mettre en
place des méthodes efficaces pour
récupérer les métaux bon pour ça on a
principalement recours à des méthodes
utilisées dans l'industrie minière
hydro-métalurgie électrolyse
pyrométallurgie le problème c'est
qu'elle présente de nombreux
inconvénients sur le plan
environnemental par exemple la
pyrométallurgie utilise beaucoup
d'énergie et se fait dans l'immens
centre situés principalement en
Allemagne alors on a rien à priori
contre la Deutsche qualitat mais bon ça
coûte bonbon niveau bilan carbone après
pour redistribuer les ressources partout
sur la planète
et vous l'aurez deviné c'est pour ça
qu'on est là aujourd'hui des
scientifiques ont peut-être bien trouvé
la solution ces chercheurs parisiens du
laboratoire sciences et ingénierie de la
matière molle à l'ESPCI ont en effet mis
au point une méthode astucieuse vous
connaissez le fameux théorème de des
proches un manquablement quand on plonge
un corps dans un bain moussant le
téléphone sonne et pour contrer ce
maléfice les chercheurs balancent
justement le téléphone mais aussi
ordinateur et autres télé dans des
mousses aqueuses
et ça change tout car jusqu'ici on
emploie surtout des solvants qui ont un
gros inconvénient il génère de grandes
quantités d'effluents polluants comme de
l'acide sulfurique et du cyanure
concrètement comment on procède tout
d'abord on broie les déchets ça c'est un
grand classique quand tu la regardes un
mec tu l'abandonnes pas intact à la
terrasse d'un café tu les crabes un peu
d'abord
et ben avec les claviers d'ordinateur
c'est pareil pour les recycler on ne les
plonge pas tout entier dans un bain car
oui on parle ici de mousse qui ressemble
furieusement à celle de votre baignoire
ici pour nous faire une démonstration de
leur manip les chercheurs ont concentré
l'argent issu des déchets électroniques
sous la forme de petites plaques
on les plonge dans la mousse qui
contient de faibles quantités de
tensioactifs qui permettent de fabriquer
des bulles mais aussi de l'ammoniaque
le dioxygène présent dans l'air contenu
dans les mousses permet alors une
oxydation rapide et efficace de l'argent
qui se dissout dans la solution sous
forme d'ion ici pour la démo on voit que
la solution devient bleu sous l'effet de
cette dissolution ça s'appelle la
lixiviation hein quoi non non mais là tu
es en vente des mots on me la fait pas
oui bon il y a quelques nuances mais en
gros ça veut dire dissolution sauf que
ça fait plus scientifique et puis c'est
pratique au scrabble quand tu sais pas
quoi faire de tes I et de TX ah non mais
moi je joue plus avec toi c'est mort
quand on compare la plaque avant et
après on voit qu'elle n'a plus le même
éclat une couche à bien disparu là on a
une plaque avant l'expérience qui
entièrement poli et qui brille et une
fois qu'elle a été lexiliée la surface
devient rugueuse on peut voir que elle
était terne par contre la partie qui n'a
pas réagi que ça va être support elle
elle brille encore
et dites vous que ces plaques sont mille
fois plus épaisses que les métaux qui
sont sur les circuits électroniques donc
ça veut dire que ça marche largement
sachant que l'argent est très difficile
à dissoudre et que cette méthode est la
seule qui ne soit pas corrosive et ne
pollue pas bravo les chercheurs on peut
ensuite assez facilement récupérer ses
métaux pour les réutiliser ce qui n'est
pas du luxe sachant qu'il reste environ
17 ans de réserves d'argent disponible
dans le monde alors qu'on en met
absolument dans tout
a priori rien n'empêche ensuite
d'étendre la méthode à d'autres métaux
comme par exemple le cuivre en changeant
un tout petit peu la recette ce qui
ouvre des perspectives prometteuses pour
recycler les métaux contenus dans nos
vieux frigos tablettes et autres
Tamagotchi momifiées sans massacrer
davantage l'environnement pour l'heure
cette méthode en est au stade
expérimental il y a donc fort à parier
que vos prochains téléphones ne finiront
pas dans ce bain moussant mais ces
travaux ouvrent une perspective
salutaire qui pourrait nous permettre
très bientôt de réduire tant la
pollution que le gaspillage et ça c'est
vraiment pire anxissant non mais là
vraiment t'invente c'est pas possible
peut-être
si vous aimez les soirées mousses mais
aussi les solutions pour l'avenir de
notre environnement et que vous avez
kiffé cet épisode alors abonnez-vous
partagez nos contenus et allez voir nos
autres vidéos à bientôt
[Musique]